- In April, we had the
Backstreet Boys here.
Obviously we had a lot to connect on,
especially when it comes to life on tour.
So check this out.
(audience claps) - [Kelly] Wow.
- Two baby girls, both born in Vegas.
- [Howie] It's those cold winters.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, congratulations.
(laughs)
Yeah, congratulations
though, that's exciting.
- Yeah.
- So is that gonna be hard to like leave?
I mean, I know you get like,
it's nice because you
get to actually sleep
but, like
(chuckles) I've had babies.
But is it kind of hard
'cause they're so little?
- I mean, so my daughter
just turned 11 months old,
and my other daughter
is over two years old,
actually about to be three,
and yeah like I said,
we've had time back home with them,
and I've been driving them to school,
making them breakfast.
- That's so cool.
- Like doing the whole
stay at home dad thing.
And now, thankfully,
we have some shows coming up in Vegas
and that's where I live,
so basically I can just drive to work
and then go do my job. -
[Kelly] Oh, that's awesome.
- [Howie] We take them with us
on tour in the summer times.
It's like a National Lampoons Vacation.
- [Kelly] Yeah, it's like all the kids,
like the whole bus. - It's like a convoy.
- [Kevin] We each have our own bus
and we all have our families on the buses.
- [Kelly] - I was gonna
say, it has to be different
obviously when you start out.
And it is a big thing,
people don't realize like...
You're on stage,
your voice goes away when you're tired,
you have to get sleep.
But like even me, like
when I went on tour,
like after having my first kid,
I was like, 'cause I'm not like a,
I don't just like, let
someone else raise my kid.
- [BSB] Right, yeah. -[Kevin] Absolutely.
So it's like you are exhausted
when you get on stage.
- [BSB] Totally.
- But you get so much out
of it though too you know.
- [Kelly] Totally.
Yeah, yeah. But it's one
of those things where
it was different to navigate.
Like even shows and like my
kind of rituals beforehand,
and getting like my,
are y'all experiencing that?
Like how you're gonna prepare for that.
'Cause it's a different
thing going in as parents.
- [BSB] Absolutely.
- Yeah I think we all have
different systems probably.
You know, because I have
a soon-to-be 20 year old.
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh my God,
I didn't realize that.
- [Brian] Life is -
- Oh my God, we're all old.
- [AJ] I know right, ugh.
Oh my gosh.
- [Kelly] I can't even,
I didn't even know that.
- Yeah, he's in country music.
- Oh, that's amazing. -
Yeah, it's a thing to,
I mean it's a lovely thing to watch but
- [Kelly] Yeah
as I've seen these guys have kids too,
it's just kind of like,
Oh you're there now.
Haha!
- [AJ] Yeah.
- Good luck with that.
- Good luck with it.
- It is so difficult, but
it is worth it though.
'cause it is cool to be
able to be at this place
in your career where you
can afford to like have
your whole family there,
and you're not like struggling, you know.
- We have amazing wives, honestly.
They are truly the heart, backbone.
- [Kevin] Yeah they hold it down.
- Yeah they hold it down.
- [AJ] Rocks.
- I have an amazing sister
wife, my nanny. She's amazing.
I call her my sister wife.
I'm like, she's awesome.
It is, you can't do your
job without having help.
And it's a beautiful thing to
have somebody that you love and trust
with your children.
- Totally - [Kelly] An awesome thing.
- [Howie] I was gonna say
it's kind of cool though.
'cause when we first
started in this business
almost 30 years ago.
We were just young kids you know.
We were like kids in a candy store
just seeing the world.
- Yeah.
- And I think like now
looking back to where,
how it started and you know,
over time sometimes the freshness
kind of goes a little bit stale.
But bringing our kids out,
and them actually get a
chance to see the world,
and seeing it through their eyes.
- Yeah.
- Constantly keeps it fresh for us.
- Absolutely.
That's the thing with kids,
everything is kind of
brand new for you again,
because you're like seeing
it through their eyes.
It's really cool.
I wanna come back wait.
Did you say your kid is in country music?
Is that what you were saying down?
- [Brian] Yeah.
He's in country music.
- [Kelly] Okay wait,
We should just get him on.
I love country music.
I just didn't know that,
now I'm very much into this.
- [Brian] Okay.
Well you have your people call my people.
- Okay I will. - [Brian] There you go.
- [Kelly] I'll like make the
plane and fly it down to you.
- [AJ] Yeah. -[Brian] Thank you.
- No, that's so cool, that's exciting.
As a parent, like you're
in the music world,
and for your kid to kind of go
into the music world as well.
That's really flattering.
- [BSB] He's really talented.
- [BSB] He's a great talent.
- It's great to watch.
he started on Broadway in
New York when he was 12.
- Wow.
- So he's a, I mean, this
is all he knows, you know
that's the thing, that's
a blessing about it.
He's like dad, I don't know
if I could work a normal job like,
because during COVID he
wrote like 200 songs.
- Well there was a lot of time, right.
- [Brian] Yeah there was a lot of time.
So, but I'm just super proud,
like we all are super proud of our kids
- [Kelly] Oh that's so cool.